Power Wheel
this is going to fall over okay so
um members welcome to um tonight's
licensing appeals committee
um just some emergency evacuation
announcement there's no planned fire
drills so the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
by the nearest fire exits which are here
or right behind you
um five or 70 points in the island in
front of the main building please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings and please do not return to
the building until you're given
permissions through Subway Council staff
please also note the meeting will be
audio recorded as usual please make sure
that all your mobiles are either
switched off or silent I appreciate it
did it myself actually
okay
there's no filming is that
right members there's as usual now there
is a need to use microphones during the
meetings so when I invite you to speak
could you please wait until there's a
microphone free in front of you and have
you all got I can notice there's one
there are there enough okay good okay
um before speaking to the microphones
are needed to hit the hearing Loop and
all go through the audio recording
uh these are all switched on and ready
to use as pleased to speak and they'll
be unmuted by the officers behind me
please make sure the microphone is close
to your mouth before speaking speak
clearly members voting will be done on a
show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for show of
hands four and then against
recommendations we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting should there be any
okay item one is apologies
for absence we received apologies from
councilor Mrs Squires Coleman and also
councilor Michael hoy
and councilor Sharp
a gender item two substitute members
I'm aware accounts are standing your
substituting for Council sharp is that
great thank you okay
and if counselor Reeves makes it and
you're substituting as well but okay
item number three non-members attending
I have none notified I don't see any
rounds thank you
item number four minutes of the meeting
held on the 21st of July 22 they've been
circuited members
um has everybody had a chance to read
them and do you all agree that they are
accurate representation of that meeting
anyone against
that was great
sure
okay item number five is Declarations of
Interest any Declarations of interest
and was
okay thank you so item number six is a
summary of the report the effectiveness
of the earn as you learn scheme remember
Stephen green the principal license
officer licensing officer will introduce
the report Mr Greener thank you
very much oh that got a little bit loud
there
um I have produced the report and I
apologize I will highlight it early on
there is a typing error at 2.4 where I
have put 2016 instead of uh 2026. so I
apologize for that one it is quite a
lengthy report there's lots of facts
figures information I think it's about
14 pages of information uh quite a lot
to digest and take in so what I have
done is you also on your tables have got
a copy of a summary presentation which
is just outlining the key sort of points
that are in the report
and I will go through them
I have also put it on the main screen so
hopefully that people can see that at
the same time
so the purpose of the report is to
review the effectiveness of the earn as
you learn scheme which was implemented
in January 2022.
the aim of the scheme was to increase
the number of licensed drivers within
the district whilst maintaining the high
standards required to obtain their
license I believe a lot of people were
here on that decision we highlighted
that during covid we lost a lot of
drivers
and we were seeing that there was a high
demand for the taxi trade and
unfortunately we couldn't Supply the
numbers of drivers compared to the
demand and we were concerned around some
people having to wait up to two hours to
get home in a taxi so we introduced the
scheme obviously with your support
so as I've already mentioned on the 18th
of January
2022 licensing and appeals committee
approved the introduction of the earners
you learn scheme the main purpose of the
scheme I think it's quite important to
go back to the original purpose to help
with the evaluation of the effectiveness
of the scheme first of all there was a
national shortage of drivers since the
pandemic existing drivers have changed
their work patterns this is impacted on
the availability certainly on a Friday
and Saturday night and the trade felt
that the current requirements in place
to obtain the Hackney Carriage drivers
badge took too long as this could take
up to six months to go through the
process
so what what we in
as part of the scheme we broke it down
into two sections first the
responsibility of the drivers and then
as The Operators first of all is the
drivers they'll be issued with a badge
once they've completed all the
appropriate aspects except for the
Knowledge Test they'll be issued with a
private hired drivers badge for nine
months and they must pass the Knowledge
Test within nine months failure to pass
the Knowledge Test will result in the
driver's badge lapsing and they would
not allow to be reapply again within 12
months of the conclusion of the expiry
of the badge
in relation to the operator they would
take on the role as a mentoring scheme
and they would work with the drivers and
it would only be with the four one of
the four main operators that we have
within the district they are Andrew's
best tax 24 7 and Alpine
they must ensure they are signed to work
solely within the Roger district and not
subcontractors to operate outside the
district
the earn energy land badge will place a
requirement on The Operators to work
with the license holder to encourage
them to obtain their full badge any
concerns relating to a driver must be
reported to the licensing team
immediately
and will ensure that energy learn
drivers will only drive private hire
vehicles and can only work on
pre-arranged bookings
and they will help the drivers by means
of financial support and assistance with
their knowledge tests
Okay so we've got some baseline
information for you
first of all is what do we compare with
England and outside London back in 2015
so pre-pandemic and then in 2022 when we
introduced the scheme
so for private hire drivers across
England outside London they had 85 000
drivers and that increased to a hundred
and fourteen thousand two hundred
drivers which was an increase of 26
percent
Rochford we had 94 drivers in 2015 and
then we had 136 in 2022 but this was
actually impacted by the amount of
school contract providers that we had at
the time we had a lot of
um School contracts that left South End
and then came to roched
in relation to private hire vehicles in
England
again in 2015 they had 95 000 500 and in
22 they had 122 000 so they saw an
increase of 21.8 percent whereas in
Rochford we had 57 and then we reduced
to 49 so we actually saw a reduction
compared to the rest of the UK
and the carriage drivers this is the
main uh the real sort of big bit for us
um in 2015 there was 27 100 drivers
across the UK outside London and
um in 2022 there was 71 700 and there
was a slight difference or reduction of
0.56 percent
however Rogers was very different we had
258 drivers in 2022 we reduced down to
207 which was a 19.9 reduction
sorry
question Council cross
thank you can I just clarify
um the start of the scheme clearly it
was approved in January 2022 when did it
actually start and do these 2022 figures
here
um are they after the scheme started or
before this was prior to the scheme
starting and it was about I'm trying to
think actually I think it's about three
weeks later that we had the scheme up
and running so it we turned it around
very quickly to get it up and running
certainly in February we were up and
running
thank you
okay and in relation to hunting Carriage
Vehicles again you can see there that
rotched I'll jump to this because it's
quite long we had 226 vehicles and then
in 2022 we dropped down to 130 Vehicles
so we saw a 51 reduction in Hackney
Carriage Vehicles just in that short
period of time
so
we've got some again some information as
to most up-to-date I did it up until the
18th of January
um which is effectively 12 months
exactly from the date that we had the
the
um original meeting we have got 189 taxi
drivers we have uh 40 earn as you learn
drivers so potential Hackney Carriage
drivers and we've got 114 Private hire
drivers which obviously includes the
school contract providers so in total
we're at
343. if you have a look compared to
January in 2022 in relation technique
Carriage drivers we've actually lost
more Carriage drivers
since we had the initial meeting last
year
yeah
with the school contract higher they
don't pick up on weekends and stuff they
just did a school contract they so they
are
for higher vehicles but not for higher
Vehicles absolutely yes these are
specifically contracted drivers to go
and work with the schools to work during
the week only with the school pickup and
drop off they don't do any other work
apart from that and how many of those
are there do we know offhand if not
don't worry
I'm sure if we can we can look it up for
you
um I think it's it's a fair few we've
got quite a lot because we took on a lot
from
um vectio that was originally South End
um and then license with us
um but I'll ask Harris to look those
figures up for you is that right
prepped for everything else apart from
that one
so
that gives us a sort of a baseline is
where we are around the numbers
um but it's not all just about Baseline
numbers I wanted to also get the views
of the people that are going through the
scheme themselves the owners you learn
drivers and I sent out a survey out to
all the the 40 drivers that are on the
energy land scheme I specifically told
to them I wasn't going to ask their name
I didn't want to know their details all
I wanted to know was what operator they
worked for and then there was another
another number of other questions such
as the times that they worked days of
the week so they felt comfortable to
fill it out accurately rather than what
we wanted to hear as such
so
71.4 of the people responded
um were completed the survey for me
uh 57.1 of those worked for Andrews and
uh 42.9 worked for best tax
they are the two main operators that
took advantage of the scheme
35.7 of the responders has held a
license between three and six months
and
46.2 percent had attended a knowledge
school at least once a week or more
um unfortunately this is the little bit
that is concerning 30.8 of them at the
time said that they've never been to the
knowledge school even though that
obviously was one of our requirements
that we asked for
um and 85.7 of them felt that the
council should continue with the energy
land scheme so they obviously felt that
it was quite good right I've got lots of
hands now
I beg to put on my work
but forgive me Members without seeing
the order in which your hands went up
you mind if I start from left to right
council Mrs McPherson thank you chairman
um
the 30 uh 30.8 they've never been to a
knowledge school
I wonder if you know anything behind
that as in did some intend to do this
just for the nine months and not
actually do the Knowledge Test
uh I have spoken to the learning
training schools around it
um some of them well one of the
knowledge schools particularly and
you'll see this in the stats a little
bit later on found that they were
struggling to get the people in because
they were trying to earn the money first
and then were worrying about passing the
knowledge test at a later stage what
they thought that they could do was work
certainly for the first few months build
up some money and then attend the
knowledge school and then obviously cram
it in right at the last minute before
the deadline
and that was fed back to the um back to
us via the knowledge school one of the
other knowledge school has operated
completely differently as part of their
higher agreement they had to attend or
the agreement they had as part of the
scheme they had to attend weekly they
didn't have any option so two operators
ran the scheme very differently and
you'll see that in the figures as we go
further through
women and I expect one of those is more
preferable the way that it was ran
yeah
council Mrs Mason
thank you chair and we've got some
lovely percentages here
but you haven't told us what the total
is how many responded okay it was
look up those exact numbers for you like
say 71 of them replied
I'll look it up I've got it on airport
it's just on 71 of 100 is different to
71 no 71 of 40 drivers so I will quickly
work out my raps
did all 40 respond no no not all forces
we need to know the number
said that 30.8
saint
and you don't know who they are as
you've stated and you didn't want to
know how how are you going to make sure
they do this Knowledge Test
uh we specifically ask them as to what
operator they worked for
um and I can go back through the
individual responses to see what
um I could look at what school that they
were working with and I did actually
raise it it was 90 all the same operator
so I was able to then speak to the
operator to say what are you doing to
address it
my question has been answered
I think minus as well
good evening
um with uh I noticed that there's 40
additional drivers
and yet again
this 30 percent of not
never been to a knowledge school
40 drivers out of 40 drivers this is
this is crazy
it really is and to see that they've got
30 35 percent have held the badge for
three to six months
there's there's a big difference here
isn't there
yeah and when we ran the scheme
um we wanted to obviously allow them the
nine months
um sort of period for them to learn the
knowledge I I think in hindsight when we
set up the scheme we should have put
something in place with the operators
that said the drivers must attend weekly
and I think that's a learning care for
us it was a new scheme that hasn't been
tested anywhere else and I think that's
the advantage obviously of today is we
can look at what has worked what hasn't
worked and then you can then determine
as to the way forward that maybe
certainly be something that you might
want to consider if that I can't preempt
but if you decide the skin to continue
that may be a requirement that you want
in there with the the knowledge schools
was only 40 drivers
applied to the it was only 40 yes I
think it State before you continue can I
just confirm that what you're saying
here is the these figures so it's 30 38
30.8 percent have not it's actually 38.8
of 71.4 percent of all the drivers yes
as opposed to 30.8 percent of 40. yes
right that's the first thing and
secondly without trying to preempt what
you're coming on to because I've been
writing several things down are you
going to elaborate a bit more on the
fact that these people haven't been to
thank you
it's okay like I say it's it's useful if
they have got any sort of questions then
please obviously do throw them
so some work
go from one at a time
um as I said one of the questions I
asked was what time do you tend to work
again as part of the original sort of
um agreement was that it was
predominantly Friday and Saturday nights
um late at night was obviously a concern
for us but if you have a look at the
chart in the yellow it shows that
certainly on the Friday and Saturday
nights the um
most regular time they work is between
six and
uh 10 o'clock at night
rather than what we originally asked for
which would be ideally the the 10
o'clock until 5 a.m sort of time so that
certainly has been fed back to us from
the drivers
if you
look at the next question that I asked
which was where would you say that the
majority of your work is located
and again I refer you to the very tall
dark maroon column
that indicates that a lot of their work
actually is in the South End area
um that obviously that gave us some
concerns as well but
there is sort of a strong area in the
red area for Rayleigh and for Roger also
during the evenings as well
okay
key question that I felt was important
is as an end as you learn driver
how confident are you that you think
you're going to pass that Knowledge Test
in nine months
one being very confident
and five being no not confident at all
I'm really worried
I would say that
some I think are from a certain
knowledge school that are very confident
and unfortunately if you look at column
four and column five there is quite a
high percentage that have indicated that
they're not confident that they were
going to pass that Knowledge Test I
don't know whether that's because it was
early on in the process that
they were in the early stages of going
through the badge and just driving and
learning
but there was a clear sort of separation
between the two I can tell you the
majority of the ones that were very
confident was working for one operator
castrated
I'm probably going to ask another
question you're not gonna know the
answer to
um as they haven't got the knowledge and
they're learning their knowledge what
are they usually setting apps to get
around at the moment yes because they
know exactly where they're picking up
and dropping off they are able to use
sat nav's
um I as part of the scheme what we did
also introduce
and I brought one with me is around
feedback we were really really keen on
getting some feedback to see how the
energy learn scheme was operating
and what we introduced and since then
we've not only done it for our energy
learn drives but we've done it now for
everyone else as well is we've put a
headrest band in the back of every
single vehicle and it says how did I do
in the middle
is the plate number of the vehicle
and they can either scan a QR code QR
code if they've got a technical phone or
if not we kept the web address really
really short
that takes you directly to a form that's
on the rotches council website
and we ask that question how did you
find the driver The Journey
um have you got any concerns and they
that information gets back directly to
us we've had lots and lots of feedback
that has been submitted which is really
really positive
um I'm pleased to say we've only had one
person that's come back to say any
negative over the entire 12 months so
that's really really good that we were
able to get the information directly
rather than relying on The Operators
from telling us what we wanted to hear
so certainly we've not had any concerns
have been raised to us about people not
knowing where to go
or the driver being unsure because
they've been able to use their mobile
phones for the satin episode facility
I know there's questions yeah cancel
cancel cross thank you chairman
I'd just like to ask um as it as it is a
prerequisite that they can only
use pre-booked fares
um
how is that enforced it is it um is it
down is the onus on the operator to
ensure that that's what happens yes
under the legislation um under the
operator's license they can only deploy
vehicles that are approved under their
operator's license so the vehicles will
be assigned to their computer system
they will then send the jobs out to the
drivers at the vehicles of the place to
pick up and where to drop off and so
they control it is there any possibility
that they could take additional fares no
if that happens then they're breaching
legislation and we would revoke their
licenses immediately okay thank you
I can't understand
thank you chair
um
this knowledge that they are
it looks very much like 50 and not
confident uh in what they're doing and
and they're using Sat Nav
um it's a bit
they won't pass if they use a Sat Nav
that's for sure that's correct Sat Nav
is not a good idea in any case
um with that in mind and the faulty that
have applied for it basically you're
looking at half to to get through with
this knowledge
is that going to be
is there an is there any more take-up
than those faulty since in halfway
through this experiment that we're
dealing with to accommodate those extra
20 or more to do to go through it and
where we've got
it says 50 are confident in in passing
is there an interim
exam if you like or a test an interim
test just to give them that little bit
of knowledge because 50 are not
confident so I feel that there should be
some intervening program to to test them
in in say uh three months or four months
that sort of thing so to make life to to
give us confident that this is because I
don't feel as though this is working
very well if you've got 50 that that
won't pass okay
um we have got the up-to-date figures
because we preempted that was was going
to be asked
um today we have currently got as of
today
um 43 earn as you learn drivers working
at the present time
we've got in addition to that we've got
nine that have actually passed uh their
full process and pass their Knowledge
Test
and we have got 12 applications that are
currently going through the stages at
the moment in preparation to issue their
own energy land badge
so that's 64 in total as of today
in relation to
um about knowledge the knowledge schools
issue out modules at a time to learn the
district because there's a lot of the
roads in the district to learn the way
that we do the Knowledge Test is a
computer-based test so it's multiple
choice we don't know what the questions
are going to be we've uploaded thousands
and thousands of Roads into the system
so it could be absolutely any Road in
the district that could be chosen and
then we ask what is at either end of
that road even whether it's a lake or if
it's a dead end we ask those sort of
questions the knowledge test is not easy
it is very very difficult to get through
and we I know that we had the discussion
here before as to whether it is the
Knowledge Test worth keeping I think so
it shows dedication for them to actually
know the area like I say a Sat Nav
doesn't always give them the best route
or the right route
so you do need the actual knowledge at
the same time so like I say the the
knowledge schools do work closely with
them and like say they won't give out
the next module until they're ready and
they feel confident
um like I say one of the knowledge
school is working very very well like I
say and as we go through you'll find
that one of the the other knowledge
schools isn't working as well as we
would like and that will be part of
obviously for your discussions for
yourselves just sorry sorry just before
we before I come to yourself because Mrs
Mason can I just point out that as we go
through this it's quite clear that
there's a number of questions coming up
and concerns if it turns out as a
committee we decide that we want to keep
the scheme we are just checked we are
able to add recommendations a bit like
we do on over in scrutiny so I don't
know if that's an option you may want to
consider
Mason
yes thank you
um you'll be aware of this because I
emailed earlier that um I have some
concerns one of them which has come up
now so I'll raise it now is the fact
that we say they must ensure they're
working solely within the Rochford
district and all the information we've
got makes it quite clear they're not
operating solely within the Richer
District so 6.2 and 6.6 uh contradiction
and I have asked for some clarity but I
think we have some concerns we've got
concerns I've heard about the knowledge
concerns about the pickup points and
concerns about the number and
uh forgive me but I think it'll be
helpful if we heard the whole of the
presentation and then if we decide as a
committee that we want to go ahead with
this perhaps look at the specific areas
of concern and see how they can be well
addressed if that's the right no I I I
and I I that had crossed my mind I
wasn't expecting the reason I have my
head down actually early was I wasn't
expecting questions so early but I am
conscious that there's a lot of
information here and by the time we get
to the end of it your questions may be
forgotten and so that's why I've sort of
done it but you know if we can let Steve
go go on and that really and I do agree
with cancer Mr Mason Council Mr
McPherson
uh I'll try and keep this beef um on
your on your graph when you asked
um whether they're confident and not
confident obviously you've asked that at
a certain time so some of them may not
have even engaged with the knowledge
school so that's going to reflect in
there quite clearly there's
um some direction here when we're
looking at the recommendations about
them starting that knowledge school
early and possibly the weekly sessions
and also on your chat chart where you
showed their time spent in South End my
understanding is the knowledge that they
learn is of our district not of South
End and you mentioned that you had some
concerns around that are you going to
bring that up further on in this yes
yeah I'll raise that because again it
was part of the original agreement was
that they solely worked in the rochered
area and like say information from the
drivers have clearly indicated that that
didn't happen okay wonderful and yes
chairman I will keep everything to the
end now because that makes perfect sense
thank you councilor Mr Lambert if it's
brief then other than I will let Mr
Greener continue
um on the out of area
bars on the um where do you earn your
money
are we saying that that work is solely
in south end or Castle point or is it
that somebody using castlepoint and they
want to come to Rayleigh or they're in
Rayleigh and they want to go to Castle
point
yeah the question I asked was just where
would you say the majority of your work
is located so it could be that the
pickup is mainly at South End and they
drop off a ratchet or it could be in
Castle point but I'll go on to some
other bits and pieces of information
that were also passed on to me by The
Operators that will then actually help
you get a little bit more information
around that with the statistical
information
um just to go back to one question that
was around the school contract and the
number of drivers that we have we have
32 Live school contract drivers at the
present time and we have 10 currently
going as through the application process
to become School contact drivers
okay right uh the next one I want is to
obviously just highlight to you
um was when the badges are likely to
expire
um I thought that was quite useful to so
you could actually see
um that over the next sort of few months
when are the the badges are due to
expire as you can see some were already
in February some were in March and then
it goes all the way through to September
with the majority of the badges that are
due to expire in August
so that was the feedback that we had
from the drivers from the survey
there was positive and there was
negative in there but what I wanted to
do is just go through a example of one
of the drivers that did go through the
process
which is Glenn and Glenn as said that
he's happy for me to include all his
details in the report so Glenn started
with the knowledge school on the 22nd of
February 2022.
um he went through the process and he
was awarded his badge on the 10th of May
2022 so that was two months and 18 days
after he started the course that means
that he had done all the DBS checks all
the safeguarding training all the
disability awareness driving assessments
he had met all the requirements the only
thing he hadn't passed at that stage was
the Knowledge Test
on the 28th of July 2022 Glenn came and
took his knowledge test and he passed
first time
and he was then we changed over his
badge from a private hire driver's badge
that same day over to a hat and he
Carriage drivers badge and he began
working in a taxi the same day so it's
just to prove it can work
I asked Glenn for a bit of a comment as
to why he felt that the scheme was right
for him at that time in February and I
don't really need to go through the
whole lot
but it's emphasized really that one is
down to
having a good tutor
and it says that if the course wasn't on
the as a learned scheme I wouldn't have
started and it had been organized
extremely well and affordable being a
taxi driver is completely different from
working from the usual nine to five you
can become more flexible for family and
still make time up at any point of that
day or week it's also being very
financially personally the scheme should
continue as it's an excellent trade
to get into if you're willing to put the
hours in and again that is the key bit
for me that's really standing out if
you're willing to put the work in and to
work hard then you will get the rewards
and that has been evidence from
certainly from Glenn's experience
go on to an operator again I asked the
operators for information to help me
look at this in a bit more detail how
has it worked for the operators and I
I ask you to look at this with a bit of
caution the reason for that is the
operators have financially benefited
quite considerably from the energy learn
scheme
because the drivers have to go and work
for them obviously they generate money
from hiring of vehicles of radio rent
and obviously you've got extra drivers
out there which obviously extra income
for The Operators so from an operator's
point of view yes it has been a very
successful scheme but
there is key points in the report and
the perspective from the operator that
is quite good to see these strong and
again you can read it but it's the key
point at the end lastly thank you for
all your support it's truly refreshing
and a pleasure working with you we
believe that you have a balanced view in
the interest of all parties the public
the drivers and the circuit operators I
strongly recommend that this scheme
remains in place
from the second perspective this has
been a major success as without the
support our customers would have been
stranded on the streets late at night as
post pandemic we have lost drivers and
ultimately coverage so from a operator's
point of view they have seen an
advantage to it
so I asked the operators for all the
information their bookings in relation
to the jobs that had been given to the
energy learn drivers and also the number
of bookings that they had taken by their
operator's license during that time
period And this is between July 22 and
December 22. there was a question that
has been put to me around how come that
there is Andrews have got 25
000 sort of allocated bookings whereas
best tax have got 69 000 Andrews have
got two operators bases one that is in
the Roger District Aviation way and one
which is in south end so even though the
call center will take about the same
amount of calls they will split them
equally between the rochered and the
South End area
so where you've seen the best hacks have
taken a lot more jobs is just because
they've only got one base which is based
in Rayleigh rather than spreading it
over the two operator spaces that they
have
but you can see the the percentage of
work allocated out to the earnings you
learn is very very similar you're
looking at about 27 28 of the work that
as they have dealt with has been dealt
with by the earn as you learn drivers
okay and this then leads on to
a real interesting bit like say in the
actual main report I'd put it as figures
um but I thought it was actually quite
helpful to see it as a map to actually
see because I I have to admit I had to
look out what the ss1 postcode was
because I didn't actually know it
um but looking at a map it gave me a
better understanding as to what areas
that it covers
so what I've used here is because there
was lots of facts and figures and lots
of bookings that they'd given me
so the chart that I've included is based
on those figures that were provided to
me between July 22 and December 22 and
this shows the pickup locations not the
drop-offs all the drop-off locations are
inside the Rocher District so I had to
use either the pickup locations or the
drop-off locations to get a postcode I
couldn't use both at the same time
because it was going to skew the figures
because you're going to effectively
count twice
so I use the pickup locations the reason
why I use the pickup locations is that
the key points that has been highlighted
by the drivers was that the majority of
the work was in the South End area if
the majority of the workers in the South
End area that's where they're going to
be picking up the drivers picking up the
passengers from so it was vital for me
to use the pickup information
with the information that's been
provided to me like I say it gives me
what the drop-offs have been within the
Rocher District
I am not sure whether there may be some
jobs and this has come to light very
recently where the operator has
allocated a energy land driver to go and
pick someone up from Southend and has
also dropped off in south end it's come
to my attention recently
under a number a couple of complaints
from South End licensing that I've
obviously investigated and I have taken
formal action over those
so I have forgot obviously the figures
here as you can see we have Andrew's 62
percent of the jobs is within the ss4
postcode which is mainly the rochered
ashington stanbridge and pagushim area
whereas best tax which is 63 is in the
ss6 postcode which is Rayleigh which is
what I'd normally expect from an
operator that is mainly based in the
Rayleigh area
I know there's going to be lots of
questions around this
so I then went on to around the Public's
perception how have they received it
since we've introduced the energy loan
scheme and it wasn't
um coordinated by myself but was
um coordinated by someone else which
made my life a little bit easier on
social media there was a post in
November 22 which was asking the
questions around the taxi trade and how
did they find the taxi trade and their
experiences and I've just picked out
some key points that have been raised
in the main report I've answered those
concerns because I felt that we as a
committee needs to respond to certainly
the comments that have been asked and it
was right that if we highlighted the
questions and then the responses were
masked then we can obviously feed that
back to the residents in some form
so
um one of the questions was I've been
informed to the Richard licenses and
more restrictive in restrictions to
neighboring boroughs like South End who
are allowed to pick up fares outside the
area no that's not true with the work
that we've been doing we were the first
Council in Essex to introduce the United
land scheme only one other council is
introducing it next week which is
Basildon a lot of the councils are
watching what we're doing and we have
both both Karis and myself have had
national interests in the scheme via the
private hire taxi magazine but we've
also had phone calls from other councils
across the whole of the UK sharing the
real interest in the scheme
bring back Uber would definitely make it
more appealing to go out on an evening
knowing how you can get a taxi home I
know that there was a conversation with
Uber around whether they would be
interested in obtaining a license within
the district
now they are not interested in obtaining
a license within the district as part of
the Uber app they have got part of the
app that is known as a local taxi
company and one of our operators is one
of those local taxi companies that is
attached to the Uber app
uh I'll be interested to hear if there
is any truth in the rumors that the
local taxi firms have brought up all the
licenses and only issue them to new
drivers with the rental of the taxi
firms owned Vehicles now again we have
licensed a number of vehicles for the
energy land drivers they've used their
own Vehicles there is no restriction
over the number of licenses that we
issue for vehicles
most councils are making it harder and
harder for more and more expensive to
get a driver's license and basically
earn minimum wage and often abuse whilst
doing so we haven't changed our fees
since 2017. it is something that I'd
need to urgently look at because of the
costs of the equipment and the cost of
running the team that we run but it
hasn't changed since 2017.
um the last one is the more worrying one
I've tried several times several
companies for my 22 and 20 year old to
pre-book taxis for them on a night out
so they can get home and each company is
telling me in the Friday and Saturday
night they don't take bookings they just
have to ring when they want to come home
and hope for the best
that is concerning the whole purpose of
the scheme was to address certainly the
Friday and Saturday nights
um in there I have also included a
officer recommendation and I've
highlighted
two bits in there
in the second paragraph in the final
paragraph officers are concerned that
the high percentage of drivers will not
pass the Knowledge Test within the nine
month period based on their responses of
the driver's survey however it's evident
from the case study that if a driver is
willing to put in the work and work
closely with the operator they can
achieve the full handiccarriage drivers
badge within the allocated time
the licensing team are Keen still to
support the scheme however recommend the
adjustments are made to the scheme and
what I propose or recommend is that
actually limited the number of earn
energy learn applicants per operator
what I've suggested is as you're
limiting it to 10
um per operator once someone has either
passed their knowledge test or they have
completed the nine months that then
opens up a gap to then fill that single
slot so it is a rolling allocation of 10
drivers that will be working for that
operator in one time the reason why I've
made this recommendation I think that
puts pressure on the operators as well
to get the people through if they want
to have more drivers they've got to work
with the drivers to get them through
their Knowledge Test quicker which means
that they can get more drivers out there
if they are just relying on them working
for those nine months they're not going
to increase the numbers that they want
to do
personally I believe that one of the
operators has worked very very well and
we've seen that evidently wise with the
the number of pass rate in their drivers
eight of the drivers that have passed
out of the nine is all from one operator
that is with the best tax operator
um
in relation to Andrews and again I think
you can already see that from the
figures and the attendance at the
knowledge school they haven't had the
same results that we have seen certainly
over the last 12 months
this way I think it sort of forces their
hands a little bit I know Joe you can
ask me questions
right that actually does leave me on
nicely to
any questions
right sorry there was a lot of
information
thank you Stephen thank you very much
um right members okay I know there's me
lots and lots of questions I think it
might be an idea
to ask whatever questions you need to
make a decision about whether or not you
want the scheme to continue
and then if you decide that you want the
scheme to continue then we can start
talking about recommendations because
I've certainly got someone I'm sure you
have as well does that does that sound
about fair I think it's probably a good
way to go so again I didn't see Hands
going up so I'm going to start well
you're standing sitting right in front
of me cancer ft cancer
thank you
um
[Music]
with the 40
new drivers 10 each operator at the
moment we've only got two operators
okay it's actually taking us on board
would that encourage the other two
operators to take this on or would it
just be 20 drivers lost
no I have spoken to both of the
operators
um cab 24 7 which was previously based
in Rayleigh have
for me I've just merged with the
Cooperative in South End
and they are Keen to do extra work
within the Rayleigh area under the
correct rules of operating solely in the
Rayleigh area
um so they are Keen to they were waiting
obviously for today's decision as to
whether the scheme is going to continue
or not but they are eager to bring
drivers on the other one which is Alpine
again I spoke to the operator there has
been some issues with his family so he
hasn't been able to focus as much as
trying to increase the number of drives
in the area but again he is very keen to
get that moving forward and I've had an
email from him that he would be very
supportive of the scheme and also
limiting the numbers to 10.
thank you
that's a Mrs McPherson
um thank you chairman well to be honest
chairman I'm quite happy to propose that
that we go to the vote and then talk
about the nuts and bolts
okay
um
so members um I think what we'll do then
in that case then we'll take a vote on
whether or not we want to keep the
earlier and as you learn scheme
um and then
um and then we can we can decide what we
can do with it afterwards so that
proposition is made by Council Mr
McPherson and seconded by Council Mr
Mason is that correct
obviously well yes subject to amendments
okay so uh members you've heard the
proposition any uh all those in favor of
the properties please signify
you know okay that's unanimous thank you
members okay so now we've decided that
we're going to keep the scheme which is
not surprising
um let's talk about what amendments if
any we wish to make to it so did you
finish what you wanted to say councilman
Smith person um
questions that can formulate some of our
recommendations
my first question is
um best tax has obviously done very well
with this project and the way we would
like to see it go forward
I'm a little bit concerned that we would
perhaps them penalize them that it is a
10 her operator option whereas should we
not be almost not rewarding but this
operator has done good practice could
they not be offered more
I funny enough had an email from the
operator asking that exact question
my logic behind it is that at the moment
they have got an excellent selling point
for getting drivers on board
that part of their
um
uniqueness is the the percentage that
they've managed to get through the
knowledge school test and pass
with them going through
um they as you can see from the figures
I think they've had 18 drivers over the
last 12 months
if they stick to the same sort of
principles of what they've had with
eight that have passed that effectively
will open up the option for the original
tent and if they keep on the same
process then effectively enough right
um as part of the same so it'll be
effectively the same as what they've got
now
so I felt that this was a balanced
approach that everyone was being treated
the same
um but it was clearly evident that they
will achieve more than the other
operators
does that answer your question not
really
thank you it does through you chair it
does answer the question my only and I
would not start to think how we could
fit this into recommendation about the
fact that if they've done so well should
they not almost be a question of how
many do you feel that you can take that
you will successfully get a high
percentage through the Knowledge Test
you feel this confident you feel I mean
you know the industry better than we do
is you feel confident they could be
reasonable rather than try and swell
them more than they can actually
um deal with
yes but my concern is I'm trying to keep
a level balance with all the operators
on a Level Playing Field
um we have to obviously stay neutral to
not show favoritism towards one operator
than another and I would just hate to be
in a position that we get challenged
like say if by limiting it all to 10 or
it may be that we actually upped that
number it may not be 10 it may you might
want to choose a higher number that I
felt that 10 was quite a good number
because it won it focused the nice
school that they could then Focus purely
on 10 people at any one time
um but then was still sufficient enough
that bear in mind we've had it literally
open for unlimited numbers and one
operator's had 21 once had 18. you're
looking at the similar sort of numbers
for the next year
um then it is achievable to keep the
similar sort of numbers
um but it's I'll be guided by you really
um but yes obviously The Operators are
going to want more numbers
and just finally um chairman and I'll
leave it for somebody else to perhaps
formulate a recommendation but could you
clarify again what is the best tax has
done so well
because perhaps what they've done well
we can put into our recommendations
going forward
yeah I'm going to draw you into 6.10 on
the report page uh 6.9
um it's
um actually outlines the percentage of
attendance at their knowledge school
and it is very evident as part of the
agreement to work for best tax is that
they have to attend a knowledge school
at least once a week
that is very evident thank you
um I think chairman we've got a
recommendation already there then that
drivers on this scheme have to attend
knowledge school once a week
what I'll do is I'll start adding these
and then we can discuss them at the end
just while I'm writing that down
councilor um and I would need a second
for that anyway
s
well that's Mrs McPherson
I forgot what I was going to say now um
yeah thank you I presume the fact that
if we if we limit these numbers to 10
this is going to encourage the schools
or the the companies to get them through
as quickly as possible so that it opens
up for more
absolutely yeah like I say as soon as
they pass their Knowledge Test that
effectively opens up that slot that they
can then recruit another person in to
replace that person that was previously
on the knowledge so 10 or 12 would be
probably so it's a constant 10 as part
of their knowledge school
um the other reason why I wanted 10 as
well is that we have to be mindful as
well around our existing drivers the
last thing we want to do is to lose our
existing drivers that we have out there
as well I think by limiting the numbers
are now existing trade know that they
are limited to only 40
um that still allows them the the scope
to have some work as well yeah
thank you Steve before we go any further
council Mrs McPherson you're obviously
proposing that recommendation what we'll
do is we'll vote at the end did you have
a second to council Mrs Mason Council
Miss Mason Council Mr Mason thank you
yeah I'd just like to support that uh
proposal and come back on a few other
points as well the um the numbers I
think is a good idea we have to seem to
be seen to be fair and I don't think we
can however much we think that one
operator is performing better they will
automatically be rewarded by getting
their drivers through the knowledge and
therefore getting more drivers on the
circuit so it will it's it's a rewarding
scheme and I certainly would recommend
that this agree with the recommendation
that it's 10 and for all the point that
and I have raised this that I'm more
concerned about is that if it says very
clearly in the report on I think it's
6.2 that they can only
operate in Rochford on 6.6 it shows
clearly that they're not they're going
to Lee Hadley Castle Point South End now
this is a very good scheme and Roger
Council has been very Innovative and
very forward-looking and I think all
thanks to the officer for this
um in in implementing this and it's done
wonders for our residents we still have
a long way to go but we have a good
scheme what we shouldn't be doing is
disadvantaging our resistance by
advantaging other people from other
districts that haven't had the foresight
to do such a scheme so I know that their
pickup points I would want to see that
the pickup points are restricted to the
Rochford District area and not Lee
Castle
Etc because someone from South End might
be coming into our area admittedly for
an evening out
but they can use a Southend taxi they've
got more taxis but we're having our
residents are still having problems I'm
still having residents complain not so
much admittedly that they can't book
taxes which is a concern that we have if
you can't book a taxi for a vulnerable
person and it prevents them going out at
night or it means that they don't go out
or the taxi doesn't turn up we still
have that problem so we need to focus
very much on our area so I would like to
say that the Restriction is enforced
that they can only pick up in the
Rochford District area and I'd like to
propose that
thank you Joe thank you and second so
for that for noting um I'm sure Sonia
will word it better than I and secondly
the knowledge I think we've all heard
and seen in the chance the difference
that the knowledge has made and how it's
been and I would like
um attendance at those knowledge schools
to be compulsory I don't think we can
say compulsory for 100 because people do
get ill they do have holidays but I
think we should put percentage on it a
high percentage perhaps 70 I'm not
particularly fast so I would also like
to suggest that we have a percentage put
on the attendance of the schools in
order for them to carry on with the
scheme so they fall below that amount
that level that they they come off of it
I don't know if that's manageable and
I'd like the officer to let me know if
that would be practical and manageable
thank you
in uh response to the question yes we
can work very closely with the operators
and it can be a requirement as part of
the we can put it under rather than as
you learn but a operator approval scheme
that they are a approved operator to run
the scheme on our behalf and we could
stipulate that in there that they must
tend at least a certain percentage of
the night school if they don't then
we'll suspend their driver's Badges and
that will then be suspended until the
expiry date of the badge okay thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Steve
um if if the other members are inclined
to agree with that I'd like to propose
it thank you
Mr chairman yep thank you Council Miss
Mason Castle cross
um we we're thank you Mr chairman um we
seem to be coming up with different
proposals are we not going to vote on
the first proposal what we've decided
we've already voted to decide we want to
keep the scheme now we're looking at
what yeah what we want so what we're
going to do is we're not voting on
anything at the moment now there's
already a number of recommendations on
the table from the office so what we'll
do is um we'll get this get some
recommendations to get them a vote for
them if if members wish to vote
individually then I'll do that but
hopefully we can vote on mass okay right
I understand
um the question I was going to ask was
to um Stephen uh Greener and uh he did
elaborate on the rationale behind uh
restricting each operator to 10. so I
understand that
um I was going to make a proposal that
rather than restrict each operator to
10.
on a rolling basis we have a cap on the
overall
number because
um it's clear that some operators are
less willing to take up the scheme than
others Andrews and best tax obviously
are very keen with the scheme I think to
restrict them to 10 at a time is is
unfair on them if we had an overall cap
of say 40 or 50 running then the greater
proportion can be taken up by the two
that are sort of leading the way
um so that's what I'd like to say it
sounds like you would sort of trying to
propose an amendment to a recommendation
that's already been made if that makes
sense because there's isn't a
recommendation that that there should be
an increase for each operator but now
you're saying there should be I think
what you're saying is there should be a
cap on total an operators won't fight
for what they want in between
kind of yeah an overall cap and then
because clearly Alpine and the 24 7 have
not you know really taken up the scheme
at all best tax on Andrews are really
running with it and making a success of
it so I'd rather see an overall cap to
the number rather than a restriction for
each for each operator
do I need to make that a proposal or is
that a counterpro I don't really know
the protocol here but I would like to
propose that we have an overall cap
rather than individual operator caps
thank you
chairman it's a rolling figure so
I'm not quite sure I know there's been
discussion about because the because I
know the question was asked by yourself
customer about whether or not
um the operator should be restricted to
10.
um I mistakenly I've been corrected I
mistakenly thought there'd been a
recommendation to increase that but that
hasn't so that is still on the table
um
but there's you know 10 if there's only
that means if there's only 10 if there's
only two companies that take it up that
means that there's only
um let me make a note your names so and
I will come to you because I'm still
trying to work through my list
um then it means that um
sorry if there's only two companies take
it up then we're only going to end up
with 20 licenses aren't we
right okay
um
councilor Lamborn
yes I'm following up on Council across
this point surely it should be
an overall figure and then the
allocation to The Operators should be in
proportion to the number of cabs they
are running on their circuit so if we
have a cap of 40 and Andrews and best
acts are the two biggest operators they
therefore deserve otherwise deserve more
otherwise
you're giving commercial benefit to the
smaller operators okay I think I think
let's have a let's have a recommendation
and there's that's my first point yeah
are you making recommendation council
member was that was that same
recommendation that Council cross is
making it was an amendment to his in
that it should be in proportion to the
number of caps they've got in the
circuit
we're going to end up with too many
recommendations here if we're not
careful aren't we
yeah
I know and I had a point about the
pickup okay okay before you go any
further let's let's deal with the with
with Council cross's recommendation cast
across your recommendation is
just remind us again and have you got a
second for your recommendation not to my
knowledge repeat it maybe you will I
have okay right well the recommendation
is to rather rather than restrict each
operating company to 10 at any one time
on a rolling basis except that we have a
rolling 40 cap overall and
um it's kind of a first come first serve
basis I guess on how that allocation is
is split whether that's workable or not
I'm not sure but uh so is that a
workable scheme
it is okay are you happy right do you
have a second account of course
counselor Stanley okay we'll add that to
the list of recommendations discussed at
the end
councilor Lamborn you hadn't finished
yes I think
um I think it was council Mrs Mason was
saved it with the pickup Point must be
in eruptured District
I don't think that's workable because if
I'm going to South End
from Rayleigh I will get can and then
when I get there I will say to the
cabbie can you pick me up at 10 30 so
his pickup point on the way back
starts in south end but he's bringing me
back to Rochford so I would would like
to amend that to be
one of the one of the either the pickup
he's in brochure thank you
I can't amend his recommendations
already there isn't it
I think I think at the end of the day I
think I think at the end of the day
there's already a recommendation on the
table and if you don't support it then
then don't support it and I think that's
where we need to go
and I'll just point out that the cabin
your next actually on my list Chris so
thank you very much but I don't believe
the the cabbie can actually make that uh
appointment it's only if you phone
through to the office that he can pick
you up is that correct thank you
you did have your hand up cancer
standing is there anything else
um in in relation to what I wanted to
ask was
um making the stipulation that only to
pick up in Rochford or railing as as has
already been asked aren't we uh
closing down the area to the cab driver
who is on this Earth as you learn scheme
in as much as you've just reduced his
his finances drastically to pick up in
south end and also the
owners you learn scheme
um
I think that
it needs to
there's that I need to know basically is
the pass mark
um a hundred percent or is the past Mark
what is the password so when you talk
about another knowledge Tester the
knowledge yes sorry the Knowledge Test
yeah is is there a a leeway on that
Knowledge Test in as much as what
percentage is the pass Mark
um because I feel that from what I could
see from what we've just been told it
could be that you know with with
hindsight we're up maybe asking a little
bit too much I don't know I mean some
some drivers will get through the past I
mean I've I've had to go through several
tests in in my knowledge of electrical
engineering so but we've had a past at
the past Mark if you like a you know a
percentage so is that is that the same
positions
okay
um our I'll try and answer this as easy
as possible because it's it's not as
easy as you think
um right the Knowledge Test just to do a
very very quick summary um 56 questions
on the computer in 35 minutes
they are broken down by sections they
are broken down by roads I'm sure Karis
will tell me if I've got this wrong the
roads so a number of the questions will
ask what's at either end of each Road
um the next bit that we have is around
the roots it will give you uh ask you a
route so for example it'll be from
um Rayleigh Railway Station to rochard
railway station it's multiple choice all
these questions are all multiple choice
one of the routes will say go up the top
of Crown Hill Turn left one will take up
the top of Crown Hill turn right and you
then have to work out what is the
correct route to then go to the second
location
after that it's then places of interest
and normally we wear places that people
would get out of
um leave the railway station and say
right take me to
the nearest bowling alley if anyone
knows it's at Eldon way in Hockley so
it's those sort of questions that are in
the actual test
and then after that it is the highway
code highway to co-signage and then it's
finally on our conditions so there's
five five sections six session sections
they are allowed to get one question
wrong in each of those sections apart
from the conditions where they're
allowed to
so it is very very hard
if they pass all of the sections apart
from two
but they're close they're like one or
two points out
we take the liberty of saying to those
applicants right you reset those two
sections again while we're sitting here
if you pass them we'll pass it if you
don't then you have to come back again
to retake the test so we try and do a
diplomatic approach it is stressful they
Shake in the knowledge test because they
do worry about it it's a lot to learn
and it's a lot of pressure so like I say
that's why we if they are out by only
one section or they're out by a couple
we do ask them to retake those bits we
have also done it if they are not
computer literate we have verbally done
the test as well we take the time off
the test and we verbally ask them the
questions so we are able to adapt it
slightly depend on the needs and what we
identify we are Keen to obviously get
the drivers through but they must meet
those requirements
is that right
council Mrs Shaw
councilor Mrs McPherson
chairman
um just want to come back and amend my
original amendment to incorporate uh
councilor Mrs Masons because it makes
sense mine was that they do the weekly
knowledge training and councilor Mrs
Masons was that that has at least I
believe 70 attendance so that can be
Amalgamated as one recommendation I then
believe because I'm losing track of some
of the
um that the only other recommendation on
the tape at the moment is that all
pickups must be in the Russia District
because that complies with this scheme
and the legalities of it
um just one last thing and I don't think
this would be a recommendation chairman
but as it's been pointed out
our officers in this Council are leading
on this
and I think that we need to make sure
that there is a lot of publicity around
this especially when they showed us some
of the comments from our residents so
that we can give them reassurance of
exactly what we're doing to try to
support
um our residents in the scheme and
provide a good service thank you
chairman do you like a good news story
don't you
can I just before you hand the
microphone over I just need to make sure
that son is happy with what you're
recommending here so are you
recommending that um
that the earnesty loan drivers should
attend the knowledge school once a week
and the attendance at the knowledge
school should be compulsory and if it
falls below 70 then they're removing the
scheme um we're both nodding that is
perfect thank you very much
the councilor Myers yeah I mean a lot of
players been spoken about the drivers
leaving the Rochford Council but at the
end of the day this scheme was brought
in by Rochford Council for the residents
of Rochford and if the drivers want to
earn more money by going to South End
they need to pass the test to get
through the course to finish it so they
shouldn't be allowed to go anywhere else
thank you councilman
I was just going to ask with the drop
off and pick up is that
workable for drivers would that really
cut their income if they can't pick up
from south end and drop in Rochford uh
now I think that it will focus the
energy learn drivers a bit more
um certainly from the complaints I've
had recently is that the drivers once
they have done a drop-off in south end
that they've then stayed in South End to
then pick up their shop within the South
End area and not returned back to the
district I think if you introduce the
requirements that the operators can only
pass jobs to earnesty land drivers that
are the Rochford postcodes that then
forces the drivers back into the Rocha
District again which will encourage them
to be in the districts learning the
roads they can still drive around the
roads while they're waiting for jobs to
be allocated
does any other member wish to ask any
questions or speak
cancer Stanley
I've got to ask
now the this might be a little bit off
the cuff
you know what I mean
does this interfere with the human
rights of the drivers in as much as you
are restricting what their services will
provide
no I think we are doing it as a
accredited operator scheme that it is
the operator that we have asked to
coordinate this scheme on our behalf if
they don't want to operate under the
scheme then they we're not forcing them
to do that
but obviously that will make it more
difficult for them to recruit drivers
or just you can see where I'm coming
from I don't want to see us sort of
being sort of judgmental in in what we
can do and what we can't do there is a
law that says everybody's got a freedom
of
job whatever they do and and I don't
want to say that that we're restricting
it at the same time
um and that's probably you probably
think I'm going off tack here but yeah
um
if we was determined to say that could
we turn around and say that they can
only pick up fares at Rochford and have
to return to Rochford
to pick up fares that's what I'm asking
instead of
saying that they could only be that they
have to work in Rochford and I would
like could I just intervene at this
point sorry sorry because I think we've
already and please correct correct me
I've had this wrong the recommendation
on the table has already been shown that
we we can do it and it is lawful so and
I think what you're suggesting is
actually contrary to that which I don't
have an issue with but I think what
we'll do is vote on the recommendation
if it fails then maybe you could put
that forward as an alternative
is that acceptable
okay
any other member wish to speak
so what we'll do is we'll take the
recommendations the member
recommendations first
uh okay let's read them out and then
we'll see do you want to read them 100
seconds
right
right whoops
okay so the recommendation one
is that
um
earn as you learn drivers should attend
knowledge school once a week attendance
at the knowledge school should be
compulsory and if it falls below 70 then
they're removed from the scheme
okay recommendation two is that the
Restriction should be enforced that
earners you learn picker earn as you
learn pickups should be within the
Watford District
and then the final one is that rather
than restrict each operator to 10 earn
as you learn badges at any one time that
there should be an overall cap of 40
badges determined on a first on a on a
first come first served basis
those were the three Mecca Renditions so
I I guess from the reaction my next
question was going to be are you happy
to take those on mass and I suggest the
answer is no fine okay we'll take them
separately then so the first
recommendation we'll take
so I'll read out recommendation
I'll read out the first recommendation
and then then we'll take a vote on that
uh first of all so um earn as you learn
foreign
s okay
so um recommendation one therefore earn
as you learn drivers should attend
knowledge school once a week attendance
at the knowledge school should be
compulsory and if it falls below 70 then
they're removed from the scheme
okay members uh all those in favor of
that recommendation please raise your
hand
s thank you thank you members second
recommendation okay
great
it's a recommendation too is that
um
restrict the Restriction should be
enforced that earners you learn pick up
pickups should be within the Watcher
District
okay members all those in favor please
raise your hands
okay thank you members at those against
and any obsessions I don't think there
are there no
okay so that recommendation is carried
seven four and three
against
okay and then the final one
so rather than restrict each operator to
10 earners you learn badges at any one
time there should be an overall cap of
40 determined on a first-come
first-served basis
members those in favor of that
recommendation please raise your hands
okay those against
and abstentions
Okay so
that recommendation has lost uh two four
seven against one abstention
Williams
Mr chairman
um in that case may I propose
that the officers as the officers
recommend that each of the four main
operators are allocated 10 earners you
learn spaces
under an operated
try again
the officers recommend that each of the
four main operators are allocated 10
earn as you learn spaces under an
operator development scheme once a
driver has passed their knowledge test
or completed the nine month period the
slot is made available to the operator
to hire another applicant
okay so that's an officer recommendation
proposed Council Williams seconded by
Council
various Council McPherson
okay members all those in favor
those against
and abstentions shouldn't be any
okay that recommendation is passed
are there any others
yes
where is this thing
no I don't think there is
councilor Mrs Mason
thank you chair
um I was just wondering as we have
slightly altered the scheme whether this
committee would want to review it in say
six months or nine months time to see if
it's improving the service for our
residents
that sounds like a recommendation to me
yeah just clarify six months did you say
as well last time we were doing 12
months but because we have slightly
altered the scheme and undertake the
officer's advice on this would it be
helpful to review it in six months nine
months or 12 months I'm not
um very fussy about the time but I just
think we want to be very careful to keep
it reviewed and make sure that it is fit
for purpose and it is serving our
residents as we wish it to
what do you think would be the best time
to go
um
I would say nine months would be a good
review date because certainly that we
would have had
the old drivers are under the old scheme
that we obviously now to bring back into
line with the new requirements and also
we would have then had some new people
that have been coming on the scheme from
scratch because we obviously need to
bring everyone all in line with the same
sort of conditions so I'd say nine
months would be a good time for a review
they'll bring it up until December I
think can I make that a formal
recommendation please for nine months
yeah but nine months yes do you have a
second
big one were you indicating that you
wanted a second or do you want to speak
a second okay thank you
uh members so the final recommendation
is that we have a review of the earnings
you learn scheme in a nine month period
so those in favor
any against oh sorry bigger problem
sorry sorry hands up again hands up
again okay thank you
any against
any absentions
that's Carriage uh nine four and one
abstention
so that concludes
um this item and that's it
no no you've dealt with it
I didn't hear that but thank you Council
Mr Shaw we'll make sure it's noted thank
you
so members that's the end of the meeting
thank you very much for your um for your
attendance specifically